all right jeremiah yeah jeremiah where'd
you grow where are you from we're in van
nuys california
uh born and raised in l.a uh
basically at age 15 i
tried crystal meth
and wood shop in high school
really and then i became a cocaine
addict by 97 doing cocaine
and other drugs like crack cocaine
chasing that all over downtown l.a
doing whatever it takes to get the drug
into my system
what was your childhood like
childhood was a little rough my mom was
very abusive yelling at me all the time
only the free time i had was on the
weekends to go skateboarding that was my
escape route it was uh skateboarding and
drugs
and uh you graduated high school i
graduated high school diploma barely
they just wanted me out of their school
they basically gave me a diploma and
told me to leave
so by that point because of my drug use
of course of
doing doing lines in the bathroom and
just uh missing school and
being chaotic i had learning
disabilities when i was younger so it
was harder for tests and stuff so
learning learning disabilities oh i see
so
i struggled with that when i was younger
i was i was always different i had a
addictive personality and very
aggressive towards like things when i
skateboarded i took a full advantage and
went full throttle on that and then
drugs when i tried that line of speed in
wood shop when i was 15 i chased it for
now 23 years
last four years i've been doing fentanyl
for the depression i started doing
heroin about four years ago and then uh
i tried to hit a fentanyl i swore i
never tried fentanyl because all the
people are dying on the street of it
but i tried it and i've been doing over
four years straight and
i mean i lost all my teeth for the drugs
i've been doing it for about
24 years now
and i had no other as little
construction a little restaurant
experience in job industry
not much to stealing and uh panhandling
mainly
uh wherever i can i was homeless in
venice beach california santa monica
culver city l.a downtown
hollywood north hollywood for five years
so it's been 12 11 years homeless out of
my lifetime and i'm 43 now and you would
credit drugs is the reason for that yes
yes
i chose kind of be on the street at one
point for freedom
i felt free i could do i could do all
the drugs i want and just live for free
you know what i mean what are the
upsides of this lifestyle
it's uh
you know possibility you don't have any
responsibility you sleep wherever you
know i mean i like to find little places
that are dark and narrow in like the
cuts the buildings and stuff and to get
high and spend the night get high there
smoke dope all night and then leave in
the morning and start my hustle all over
again
panhandling
7-eleven is the main one you can make
good money there uh side freeways
uh i was down here downtown l.a for a
while in skid row it's a whole different
unless small crack i smell crack coming
down the park here and sit on the street
and smell crack all day and uh skid row
compared to where you're at north
hollywood oh it's beautiful north hall
is like gold
tell me about your experience on skid
row
skid row was interesting it was a
different environment
very rough i saw a lot of flights that's
all violence i saw drug use a lot of
crack cocaine down here uh speed crystal
um weed all you name it they got it down
here much more treacherous yeah it's
very treacherous down here on
in downtown l.a it's sad and there's so
much homeless here in l.a
it's all over north hall it's just as
bad you know the red line station
there's this is surrounded by homeless
people too and uh
you know
the tiny homes i'm staying in in north
hollywood california is great they buy
three meals a day and uh it's helping me
uh grow but i still get high in my room
and and do my thing you know i mean what
do you think the solution is the
homelessness problem in l.a
i think the tiny homes is a great
solution because uh it's helping people
uh
reconnect like i haven't been doing as
many drugs i got on methadone actually
to cut my drug use in half
and that's doing well uh
so i'm up to 80 milligrams of methadone
and uh and smoking about a
gram a day of uh fentanyl about a
hundred dollars so the stability of
having
yeah to chase because every day we've
got to get a certain amount of money to
support our habit and uh there's three
of us with the stability of having a
little roof over your head and
electricity right yeah
electricity is great to have a tv you
get to know you get to like i haven't
watched tv for 20 years it seems like
and i've been watching all the old shows
like batman and maverick and hawaii
five-o and that's kind of cool but the
having a roofer has nice i feel a lot
getting three meals a day getting
healthy again and having a shower just
the one shower is great you know
to get cleaned you don't have a shower
in your unit but there's one no there's
one nearby it's uh it's 40 units like
little houses
it kind of seems like a little
a little like a prison kind of but it's
not it's it's it's very nice and i'm
very grateful i met the people on the
street they put me in their system not
even two months later i was in the
shelter
so it's a great program and they're
helping me get a housing lecture to
section eight so then you'll you'll
eventually transfer i'll get a
transition and gain loan apartment and
they'll give you money for that yes
fifteen hundred a month fifteen hundred
dollars a month yeah it's free they're
free
and with i mean i guess it gets you off
the street you can send off the street
just
stayed clean and i'm also getting my job
back at ralph's that i messed up because
i was on drugs i didn't show up to work
and i got fired
do you think having your own place
whether it's
i think at this point i can maintain my
drug use
and get high until i want to stop
basically say it again i i think i can
maintain my drug use right now okay just
continue
get a free apartment a job save up money
uh you know give a few little
materialistic things and just enjoy life
going on beach and stuff and have fun
i enjoy getting i i will i enjoy getting
high yeah i love it you have kids no i
have no kids
and only child
do you you have friends
i have a couple
uh hi and goodbye mainly to people on
the street i never really settled down
with i have one friend on the street i
trust i know in four years
but
besides him and another person that's
the only people i really talk to i don't
have many friends i i'm a principal
loner pretty much yeah do you think of
square life where you had a nine to five
job and you were clean from drugs and
all that is even in the cards for you
yeah in the future you think yeah yeah
i'm trying right now to do that yeah and
methadone might be the way that's gonna
be a solution because it's helped me
with my hyperactivity and adding when i
get all over the place and you're hyper
and stuff
did your mom or dad have a history with
the drugs my mom went dad my dad did
drugs he did red yellows quaylus back in
the 70s listening leads up playing rock
and roll and all that uh mainly uh
he stayed with the pot for 30 years
he got uh
got caught on the job smoking pot and
they started drug testing him and he
started drinking vodka and he died two
years later with cirrhosis over
the coughing of blood and it's a
horrible death and you were old when
that happened i was uh
36. okay was your dad in your life yes
he was very important to me he put up
with all my drug habit instead of my mom
over these years but my mom was very
abusive she still is it's hard to have a
conversation with her she always puts me
down because of my drug use
it mainly uh puts me down you need a job
and this and that which i'm working on
i'm trying my hardest but i enjoy
getting high
i like the taste i like the smell like i
like the emotion of getting it
playing with it all
it's all part of the part of the high
was there any i mean was the abuse from
your mom
i think so for not letting me do what i
wanted much keeping me in the house not
only going on the weekends getting
twenty dollars and i get a ground weed
at first
and then the speed and
chasing that around all around town all
day long
robbing stealing
and graffiti all that
i mean this lifestyle this lifestyle is
uh
i enjoy most of it but i don't enjoy it
sometimes it's dangerous very dangerous
i've seen a lot of violence on the
street a lot of people carry guns a lot
of people get robbed beat up
i get robbed in my sleep
sleeping on my backpack and my backpack
will be gone in the morning and
now you know what happened you know i
mean drugs and baggies all around me
blackout uh drinking
uh all that
so very restless uh
tiny homes is hopefully gonna help me
get forward to my own apartment where i
can
have a good life
what do you worry about now
overall my health
doing drugs
i worry about my mom she's getting older
um
i will get a little money from her which
uh
i would probably use to get a condo or
something to stabilize my life
not spend all on drugs
which i probably could do it it's very
possible
yeah i mean
but right now i get a social security
check
a thousand a month and i get 35 a day
and i do on that
and uh i don't have to go panhandle
right now i said tiny homes is providing
me
not staying off the street really and
just kind of getting my drugs and hiding
in my room and getting high and hanging
out with my friend and panhandling and
stuff i still panhandle once in a while
for extra money
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you do differently
i do
uh get a girlfriend get married have a
house car
kids
a normal lifestyle maybe with like just
drinking once in a while a glass of wine
or something and uh maybe had a weed
something like it
do you wish you would
you know take a straighter path with
your life
yeah
a lot of things i do i'm 43 now i unders
i when i was 18 i was like i'm gonna
party until 25 and i'll be dead
that's why i figured i'd be dead by 25
because how aggressive my drug used to
have it was
so
i'm surprised i'm still alive right now
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
trust
trusting people
trusting
[Music]
trust is a very big issue
you gotta earn trust you know i mean
i
i don't trust many people i don't have
many friends and
i kind of like aware of all situations
when i walk out a door i evaluate
everything i keep
i'm always on you know i mean you never
know
you never know who has a gun you know
who
who's who's going to snap or go crazy
because of mental disease
you never know on the street
all right jeremiah
thank you very much for sharing your
story and i wish you the best of luck
thanks so much sir housing and
everything else thank you
you